so imagine is the founder and CEO of the
AI startup stability AI he launched the
company back in 2019 and he went through
a couple different business ideas for it
none of them really ended up generating
much revenue if any and eventually Emma
just kept going kept searching for
a business that would work
it was summer 2022 that stability really
broke out had a its big sort of almost
overnight viral moment and this came
with the launch of the generative AI
text to image generator called stable
diffusion this is a model which allows
you to type in a phrase anything from
your imagination and can generate uh
almost instantly an AI generated image
I interviewed him three times once in
San Francisco last October when
stability had its public launch party
and then again in January in San
Francisco and then in London
I think I picked up pretty early on that
uh he's a very charming and charismatic
guy and he talks a uh very large game I
think compared to most uh Silicon Valley
Founders he has high Ambitions and is
very uh very open about sharing them and
I think that's really inspired a lot of
people both
investors and collaborators but also you
know his own employees and
the general public that has gravitated
towards AI so he's developed a bit of a
cult following I think in a sense
through that
[Music]
during the fact checking process we
found that a lot of things that he said
were just very difficult to fact check
so I think this was kind of the uh the
first maybe not red flag but yellow flag
that set things off and made us start to
have some skepticism and want to look
further into the claims that he was
making as we dug in further started
talking to investors who had met with
stability started talking to former
employees we start to piece together
more the facts we started to gather some
documents
Ahmad has at least since 2017 been
claiming that uh he holds a master's
degree from Oxford University in math
and computer science he had this on his
LinkedIn at the time the stability
raised their 100 million dollars last
summer that LinkedIn has since been
deleted but we found further traces of
that dating back to you know his past
companies going back to 2017 where he
claimed this Oxford degree but in
reality we contacted Oxford and Oxford
told us that he does not hold a master's
degree he only holds a bachelor's degree
[Music]
I think one of the big unlocks was we
got a fundraising pitch deck from Summer
2022 that had
a list of I think about like 50
employees on there in one of the slides
of the document and what I found was
that there were many people that were
listed on that slide that
did not have stability on their LinkedIn
I did not have any like publicly
searchable connection to stability but
they were on this document and one of
the people uh was this person named Eric
hallahan who went on the record and
talked to us about his experiences at
the company Eric had been an intern at
the company
he spoke through the chaos of the
company a bit he had been slated to work
300 hours with a company over last
summer
and
ultimately 181 of the hours he sent an
invoice to stability in August
and
eight months later he had not heard back
he had not been paid for it
[Music]
I contacted
stabilities collaborators that uh on
stable diffusion their image generator
and I ended up getting in touch with the
professor at the German university
called Ludwig Maximilian University of
Munich and
turns out that this guy this professor
had overseen the initial research to
create the AI model that served as the
basis for stable diffusion he had a lot
of gripes about the way that stability
had marketed itself and positioned
itself as being they said in public
marketing materials the company behind
stable diffusion as this professor told
me you know stability would sometimes
take an outsized amount of credit for
you know being the company behind this
work and then sometimes it was only
after he had reached out to the company
that the company
dialed it back or you know
gave the university some credit
one thing that was really memorable to
me that he had said during the call was
that uh if you have a large enough press
Department then you can Rebrand history
in your interests and
got the impression that that's exactly
how he felt about what stability had
done so we also got our hands on a
fundraising uh pitch decks so these are
like PowerPoint presentations
essentially that the company presents to
investors that they hope to put money
into the company it claimed that it had
Partnerships with organizations
including the United Nations the World
Bank the World Health Organization they
claimed a partnership with Amazon web
services that in these slide decks they
described as a strategic partnership
they claimed that Amazon had supplied a
vast amount of AI chips at a 80 discount
to the market value when I talked to
Imad in January he told me that Amazon
had cut stability a very attractive deal
that he said came with quote unquote
certain personal guarantees when I asked
him for more information about this I
was sitting in the room with him as well
as his wife Sarah Qureshi who was the
company's head of PR at the time she
shot my question down and they just
would not go further on that
conversation point until we changed the
topic
we spoke to a vice president at Amazon
who said stability is in fact
like any other Amazon customer when it
comes to cloud computing
and he shot down the notion that there
was a strategic partnership it was
unclear like what exactly the
arrangement was and until we finally
found a couple sources who are able to
independently verify it turns out that
stability actually was millions of
dollars in debt to Amazon and that the
Strategic partnership that emad had
claimed was
not really a special deal for stability
to investors he had said that stability
had as much as a 80 discount on AI chips
from Amazon through this partnership but
after reaching out to stability for
comment they told us that this 80
discount is actually a standard discount
that Amazon offers to
anybody who wants to be its customer
with a story like this you always want
to reach out to the company to give them
a chance to respond to everything that
you plan to say about them in the story
so we reached out to them in early may
they responded to a lot of our questions
but
push back on certain things but I think
more
unusually
a key element of our story is not just
Ahmad the founder but that his wife Zara
Qureshi who was the head of PR she also
had claimed on business cards that she
was the chief operating officer and we
found that uh she was sitting on the
company's board of directors after they
obtained their 100 million dollars of VC
funding
[Music]
Ahmad took to Twitter and he also wrote
a blog post addressing some of the
claims that we had made in the story I
think stability has had some kind of uh
skepticism from a certain portion of the
AI Community I think even prior to us
publishing the story some of the
feedback we've gotten afterwards is just
a um
people being glad that this story is out
there with concrete facts rather than
you know being limited to hearsay and
back Channel I think it really speaks to
what's going on in AI right now because
of how popular generative AI has been
investors out here are just flocking to
uh fund companies uh at very Loft
evaluations throwing around tens of
millions or hundreds of millions of
dollars historically you know Silicon
Valley investors have spent weeks if not
months you know uh doing due diligence
and researching a company and
researching the founder and ensuring
that there are no red flags and they're
comfortable to invest I think the big
question will be
um
with AI being as hypey as it is now
um how mindful will investors be of
Performing due diligence of taking a bit
more time to check for potential red
flags at a company before going in on an
investment
[Music]
foreign foreign